okay good morning everybody and welcome
to
a public engagement board and i will be
chairing today um
for counsellor
oh i don't know it just told us it was
recording us but that's fine
and i'm cheering today for mike freeman
and so he's he's sending his apologies
and my name's and jane slater i'm a
councillor instructor award and also i'm
the exec member for
health well-being inequalities in
traffic and
i don't know whether or not we want to
do some introductions
and i know that i know quite a few of
you already on the call because i think
that i've chaired i've chaired a couple
in the past
and i'm only able to be on the call for
an hour so if we
just crack on and then if people want to
come in and contribute if you
just say who you are and where you're
from i think that would be
um a better way to go forward if that's
okay with people
which is the bme organization in
trafford okay
right and dorothy then do you want to
introduce yourself
it seems you on mute still ben do you
want to go ahead
uh yes no ways um hi everyone uh my name
is ben wilmot i work in public health um
and i'm the lead for testing at
traffic council okay eleanor
[Music]
no and i think what we'll do is we'll
just we'll just move on with the agenda
and we'll just introduce people as they
come in and speak if that's okay
so um have we had any further um
apologies for absence and do you know
alex
uh we've received apologies for absence
from uh councillor
freeman also from um
rebecca to maine who sent manish uh
as a replacement and nigel smith has
sent uh
julia bird uh julia burgess uh alan and
her in his replacement
and then we've received apologies from
george dublin helen collins
thomas maloney brian eaton and joanne
gibson
thank you very much um i think uh oh no
elena's there
okay um are there any declarations of
interest
from anybody
nope um the minutes of the last meeting
that was held on the 19th of
may um i wasn't as there is so if
anybody who was there could they say if
they are a
true reflection
yeah can't give the thumbs up so we'll
move ahead with that thank you
so uh then we'll if we move on to item
four which is an update of the current
coded situation in trafford
and it's over to eleanor so hopefully
she will be able to
let us are you okay thank you very much
thank you
yeah i am sorry it threw me out i don't
know what's going on today
it won't let me look at the agenda and
and the meeting so
um so the current situation in trafford
is
that um um well the good news is we look
better relative to the rest of greater
manchester the bad news is that's
because
the rest of greater manchester has
overtaken our rates and our rates are
continuing to increase so i would
i would urge the people of trafford not
to look at our relative position
um but to look at our absolute position
um certainly by the end of this um in
the next couple of days our rates will
be
over 80 per hundred thousand and they
are continuing to increase
the increase what we're seeing i think
in the country at the moment is
two different epidemics we're seeing um
one epidemic
of the previous variant
which is improving and we're seeing a
second
the second epidemic is of the new the
newest variant which is now called
variant delta
and that's that is the one that has
become now the dominant
um strain in greater manchester and
certainly in trafford
and is fast replacing the previous
strain
across the country the good news is that
that strain
is um it is the good news is it is does
still respond to vaccination
but um it certainly looks like you need
to have two doses of the vaccine you
need to have both doses
to stop you transmitting uh the virus so
it's really important at the moment that
we
continue to push hard to get everybody
who's eligible vaccinated as quickly as
possible
and that people take that second dose as
soon as it's offered to them
um because the first dose does give some
protection
but you just to get the full protection
you need to have both doses
and and of course the doses take a
couple of weeks to work in each case so
you don't have that full protection and
you can either still become ill
or you can give it to other people until
you have had both those doses and have
had
normally two or three weeks after that
so i think our main advice to people is
to be very very cautious still
most of the cases are in our younger age
population
so secondary school children and our
working age population younger working
age population
we are now rather worryingly starting to
see a few more cases in people
age 60 and above
that's at the moment people aren't don't
seem to be becoming seriously ill which
is
is probably due to the level of
vaccination but it is
as i say i cannot reiterate strongly
enough how
how important it is at the moment that
everybody is very very careful
and um particularly anyone if you have
any underlying health conditions you
know do
do continue to be very cautious um
luckily the weather is is on our side in
terms of staying outdoors because we
know that being outdoors remains much
the safest option
um and we'd continue to say to people do
avoid
noisy crowded places anywhere where you
have to raise your voice
that is somewhere where um that raising
of your voice will make the transmission
more likely
so um please please now i think if you
and i i i know all of us are delighted
to see hospitality reopening
um but again it's that message about do
be careful and
if you can work from home do work from
home because
the fewer people if we want to go out
and see friends in the evening
we have to limit the amount of other
things we do so
just make sure that if you can work from
home you continue to do that
particularly if you're wanting
to see friends and family members and so
on
um in terms of what this means for the
reopening
at the moment we we don't quite know
that'll that decision will be made
on the 14th of june um
at the moment it really does just at the
moment the vaccination program
was doing a very good piece of work at
keeping the
impact of the previous variant of bay if
this one is
it depends really how much more
infectious this new variant is than the
previous variant
if it's much more infectious then the
vaccination program won't be able to
keep up with it
if it's not very much more infectious
the vaccination program will
will hold it and that means that um the
plans for the 21st would be likely to go
on
as as we expect we won't really know
exactly how much more infectious the
current variant is for the net
for the next couple of weeks well if
it's much if it isn't much more or if
it's very much more we'll probably know
at the end of this week
if it's somewhere in the middle where
people suspect it will be
um then it's likely to be next week
before it becomes very clear
but in terms of what the options are i
mean i i
your your everybody else's guesses
will be as good as mine on this but in
the main i think
um there'll either be no change to the
um 21st date for reopening or it might
be that they push back the date
they might decide to put the same date
but with um
fewer activities fully opened
or they might decide to reintroduce
restrictions or
or possibly even do that on a locality
level and i think from a greater
manchester perspective
um i think we would be
we would be happier with a national i
would be happier with a national
approach to this rather than local
restrictions being introduced in
in any part of greater manchester um
because we know from the past that it's
actually very difficult
to maintain that and that we do see the
spread so um
my personal view is that if if anything
i would um if we did have to have any
restrictions or something's not reopened
from the 21st i would rather that was a
national policy
because i feel that the way that the uk
has worked and the interconnectedness
it makes other other methods seem very
difficult
but we're really not we don't know what
will happen at the moment
and i would say to everyone this is
currently in our hands we all have to
now do our bit to absolutely get on top
of this so
please take the vaccination encourage
your friends and family to get
vaccinated as soon as they can
don't forget that second dose the
vaccination is safe and very effective
and do be really careful at the moment
keep that social distancing
um think about what you're doing and
finally
um the test and trace system the
national testing trace system has had a
lot of flack over over the last year
but at the moment in trafford we're at a
position where
we our numbers are still um although
they're increasing they're low enough
that we can do really effective contact
tracing and we can't we are
enhancing that contact tracing trying to
speak to everybody that um
that we know is infected or is a contact
and i would really urge everybody to
take this very seriously particularly
the self-isolation
with there is support to people to
self-isolate
so have a look on the council website
but most importantly of all however
could the national testing trace and
however good our local systems are
tested and tracing they're never as good
as people who
people themselves so we know definitely
that a number of
times we've had outbreaks in settings
and those outbreaks have been really
contained because people have behaved in
such a responsible manner
as soon as they've got that positive
result they haven't waited for test and
trace to get hold of them
they have told all of their friends that
they've seen they've told any family
member and they've encouraged them to
self-isolate and go for that test
so we know that people um intrapurative
throughout behaved incredibly
responsibly and we
i can definitely cite cases where we
would have seen we were expecting to see
much bigger spreads from outbreaks
but because people have done that their
own
um tracing and told people they we have
managed to contain those outbreaks they
have managed to contain those outbreaks
so i really want to commend people and
including in that i'm going to
absolutely sing the praises of teenagers
who have done some fantastic jobs on
their social media you know we we always
give
i always try to speak up for teenagers
in these meetings and our younger
working age population
but we've definitely seen that that
we've seen people recognizing that
they've
become infected telling their friends
and getting their friends to go for a
test
and to self-isolate and that is
absolutely the most valuable thing any
of us can do at the moment
so keep up with the regular testing keep
keep be symptom aware go for a test if
you need one there's plenty and go for a
pcr test
if you have any symptoms that you feel
could be covered
self-isolate while you wait for the
results and tell your friends and
encourage them and support them to
self-isolate you
so i think those are my main messages
for today
thank you thank you very much that was
really really helpful and
some good information coming out of that
and is there anybody
got any questions on that car
yes um you know because of the
rapid rise of cases in bolton um
how are we monitoring people traveling
to and from
bolton into trafford we're not really
monitoring people traveling to and fro
because we can't we
i mean we're not doing anything um
specific for
there's really no way we can stop people
from bolton coming into trafford and
vice versa i think all we can do
is remember that we each have a
responsibility for our own safety
so it's trying to make sure that we
always keep you know
it's that thing about you it's it's an
infectious disease it's infectious
when people are asymptomatic so there's
no way of telling whether somebody has
it so i think it's just
making sure that we're all as careful as
we possibly can be to maintain those two
meters distance
and also to remember that of course your
family and your close friends are the
people who you're most likely to be
close to
so you're more likely to get it from
family and friends than actually from
strangers
so it is that um you know obviously all
of us at the moment just need to be very
very careful
and ideally if we're meeting people
wherever they're from
meet outdoors keep those two meter
distances wash your hands
wear face coverings in indoor areas
but take advantage of the weather go out
have a you know have walks and so on
just
just be careful and that that that's the
advice we're giving people
at the moment thank you
andrew did you want to come in yep
thanks um just for the the benefit of
tape
uh andrew latham i'm the chief officer
of healthwatch in trafford
um i don't know it's encouraging to hear
that the
vaccine will work against the new
variant so i just wondered on that
front have we still got pockets of
groups
in trafford that are have low uptake on
vaccinations because i know there's been
a lot of work
going on on that side there has been a
lot of work going on and we still do
have some pockets where we've got lower
vaccination uptake than others
and of course not not everyone can have
the vaccine so there are a few con
indications which mean you can't be
vaccinated but overall
we've seen a very big increase in um
particularly in the north where we've
been doing a lot of work because the
the levels of uptake and vaccination
does tend to be linked to
deprivation in particular so lower
levels
in areas of higher levels of poverty so
we are really trying to support people
to to be more confident about taking the
vaccine and we
we're starting to see that vaccine
hesitancy drop people are becoming much
more confident about taking the vaccine
there is still as i say this um we still
have a gap with our black british
um population um and as we go down the
age ranges we're starting you know we
we see a little bit more caution in some
groups as well but we are really trying
to encourage people
i think um for some of the younger
people as they become eligible
it's it's the messages really um that
kovid
is it remains a very nasty disease um
we have seen deaths in younger people
throughout
but also long covert has been you know
very very unpleasant disease and of
course
um the vaccination protects against that
as well
so we're still working um as hard as we
can to try and encourage people to take
up that vaccination
and to take it as quickly as possible
we're working with all the community and
faith groups across
across the borough to try and promote
those messages
and this group has been fabulous in
supporting that and i know
jiller is going to be reporting back on
some of the community engagement work
we've been doing
in the north we've now seen our asian
nation british
ethnic groups overtaking the white
population in terms of vaccination
update
uptake so it's um you know we're seeing
some really positive
change but um in the north we still have
a number of people from all different
ethnicities who remain unvaccinated
we're trying to increase the
availability of clinics there as well to
make sure that it's as easy as possible
for people to get vaccinated because of
course many people in that area
don't have a car and it's more difficult
for them to to get out of
to reach another site
thank you robin that's really helpful
and i think it's really positive that
because i know that you have done a very
lot of work in
some of our community well try right
across the community but i know that in
our
um
a lot of work with the inman's and and
others and it you know that
that is now feels like it's now paying
that so um congratulations to your team
and let's hope that we can
and you know move into and support well
i i
i'd like to congratulate the imams the
mosques the um
the um christine reverend aspinall at st
john's center in the north because you
know we've worked with them but they've
been doing the hard work as well as our
community engagement team
so we have had amazing engagement and
and tremendous leadership
shown by um by people in the north and
promoting the vaccinations so
um it is you know it's the local
communities have rallied round i would
say
um we've we've supported where we can
but it is about the local people owning
this
and we're tremendously grateful to them
for all the work they've done
i think it is it's really positive and i
was a person that has never been
vaccinated in my whole life and i've
told dylan story before and
i had my second code with vaccination
now and i was never vaccinated as a baby
i was the youngest of seven
i think by the time my mum and dad came
around to having me
my dad was alive now he'd be 101 so i
think that when they came around
to having me they'd given up the will to
live i think
at that time and never took me to be
vaccinated
and so i never had anything i never had
the tv jab i never had the polio shovel
lump i never had anything so
this was my very first experience of
having a vaccine
and i've been for both and i feel i feel
that i've done
something to protect me and also people
that i love and work with so i think
that it's really important if people
and you know that people go out so 59
years i've never had a vaccination and
i've
i hope it's the first of many
vaccinations for you i we
look forward to seeing you at every
vaccination clinic well
the question that i was asked was have
you ever had a a reaction to a vaccine i
want i don't know
so you better wait for 15 minutes but i
was fine i didn't have any symptoms and
other people in my family you know
they've had um
oh my day ikea was this or was that what
me i just sailed through it so i'm
really tough with myself
but yeah so really positive that you
know the communities are coming together
and we're all working really hard to
keep each other safe so it's brilliant
news
though any further questions
nope okay so we'll if we move on to a
gender item
five and is the math testing with you
jilla or is it then
that's with me cancel this later
okay go ahead yep no worries at all so
um
just a quick update then on testing so
as a response to the rising kobe debates
that ellen has spoken before we are
trialling some targeted testing work
um using additional mobile testing units
and home pcr tests
we've started in the north of the border
but i'd like to expand out
and we'll continue to identify key areas
where this will continue over the coming
weeks
um another quick update is in terms of
the direction of the community testing
program so that's asymptomatic testing
using electrical flow tests um which is
more flexible so we're going to look at
how we can further support those who are
struggling to access testing currently
and those who are most vulnerable to
covert and then
finally just continuing to reinforce key
messages on testing especially to
businesses
we want everyone to regularly test with
lecture flow tests but especially
businesses including hospitality
um and throughout all this we're going
to be communicating the key differences
between pcr testing flow tests we know
we've had feedback that
evidently not everyone is um has that
full understanding of the difference
between a pcr test and a larger flow
test
um i'm just really emphasizing how
crucial it is that people who have
symptoms
go on to go and get that pcr test
and that's the key updates for me
then does anybody have any questions for
them i think that
he's going to tell us about the
difference between lateral flow and pcr
shortly so we'll ask you about them in a
bit
anybody no okay so if we move on thank
you for that then if we move on to
um 5b contact tracing and outbreak
management
who's dealing with that
it says dalton in public health and
operations
manager so we've got i think we're
missing cater helen's on leave today and
i think
half term um so in terms of the contact
tracing and
we've got suzanne on the call who will
talk about some of this as well
um we're doing well with our contact
tracing with um
we're we've been doing um with the
new variant we decided to do enhanced
contact tracing which means just asking
a few more questions just to make sure
that we get
absolutely all the information we can um
we started doing that on sort of trying
to track where the new variants were but
actually now as it's the dominant strain
we and and because of the delay
in getting the results back about which
variant it is
so you have the test result but then the
sequencing takes a little bit longer
we decided to take the approach of
assuming that all of our cases were the
new variant
because that way we wouldn't be caught
out so we have been trying to make sure
that we've done
really effective contact tracing over
the last few weeks
and we have had a few outbreaks now
in in some workplaces we've also
seen a few cases we've had a number of
cases in schools as well
often the school's cases are
acquired outside school and then brought
into school or activities that
children and young people get up to
outside school that then means that
various bubbles have been closed and but
you know our schools have been working
incredibly hard as you know throughout
and our schools are very covert secure
settings
um but once you do have a certain level
of cases in the community it's very hard
to
not to allow any of this to get into
schools
so in terms of the work we're doing
we're sending those messages
as ben has been saying out to businesses
we're encouraging people to remain
working from home
when we get outbreaks um our
environmental health team have been
continuing to be absolutely amazing
about making sure that they
are going in and giving the right advice
to the businesses
again there's been that the lateral flow
tests aren't as accurate as the pcr
tests
and with the current um situation what
we've been advising people to do which
is a change from previous policy
but as our rates are rising we're asking
everybody who is a contact of the case
to go and get a pcr test that means that
that test will be sequenced and it's a
more accurate test so we're trying to
get
instead of waiting for contacts to get
have symptoms which is what we'd advise
previously we're now asking people to go
straight away to have that pcr test
even if it comes back negative they
still have to self-isolate
but it does mean that we can get on top
of cases much more quickly
and stop any further spread so um so
that's why people are now
being asked to do a pcr test either if
they're a contact of a known case
or if they have any symptoms just for
the accuracy and the information that
that pcr test gives us
and i know suzanne will talk a little
bit more about um some of the
work that's been going on with with some
of the businesses and making sure that
everywhere is as
secure as possible particularly as as
restrictions are lifted
um and um you know most of our
hospitality industry has been working
very very hard again to make sure that
as things open up indoors
they are they are abiding by those rules
suzanne do you want to come in
hi hi i'm susan whitaker i'm the
regulatory services manager for
environmental health
and i don't usually attend this meeting
i'm
attending on behalf of um helen grant
who's the manager
for um community safety so she's on
leave at the moment so i'm providing the
update today
and but within regulatory services and
we've been working with the businesses
throughout obviously
um the the pandemic and with the recent
step
change on the 17th of may um
communication was sent out
to all of our licensed premises to
advise them
of the changes that um have come in now
um with hospitality being able to be
taken indoors which obviously
is great news because the weather was
starting to impact on a lot of the
businesses who
opened up um outside to begin with
um but then obviously being able to use
the inside area
is really helpful to them but we're
mindful of the the spread
and that can take place more readily
within businesses
indoors um so since the 17th of may
um offices from environmental health
trading standards and also licensing
have been um taking um proactive visits
out to businesses
um and we've been concentrating on
indoor hospitality
and also soft play centres and because
this is a
business group that hasn't been able to
open unfortunately
for quite some time um and also
gyms where we've seen um some issues
so we've been focusing on those uh
premises
and also the licensed businesses and and
offering them advice
having a look around to see um what
measures they've got in place
and and and just using that contact
really to try and help them as much as
possible
generally we found compliance has been
really good
which has been pleasing and obviously
businesses are just really happy to be
able to get back to
to some kind of normal so and we've been
pleased
that that it's generally been very good
across the board
and we've also been undertaking visits
to our um sporting venues
and because as of the 17th of may um
manchester united and language cricket
club could
see the return of fans which again
that's the first time that spectators
have been allowed to be
um back in or be in obviously quite
reduced numbers
and again both clubs had done a lot of
work
to make sure that the return was safe
and we were really pleased to see all
the measures that were in place
um obviously issuing any any kind of
improvements that we could
um see but generally i don't think that
that was necessary
um so so that's been successful
we have seen um issues with a few venues
across trafford um who have been hosting
larger events
um and the police had contacted us
last week to say that they had
undertaken visits because obviously
they're they're carrying out visits in
conjunction with us as well
um to businesses and particularly to
licensed premises
and and there was a couple of venues
that there were issues with
the social distancing measures weren't
as good as they could be
so last week officers um undertook a lot
of work with these businesses
and visiting them and we also issued
written warnings to them to say that
and you know if they didn't improve then
unfortunately we would be taking action
to
prohibit them from continuing um whilst
they didn't have the covert secure
measures in place
so a visit was undertaken um late on
friday night
to two venues and uh thankfully both
had undertaken all of the work that was
necessary
and so the the venues were both able to
continue
with the events and in in a safe manner
unfortunately the police have identified
another
um venue that was undertaking
an event at the weekend um again
similar issues with lack of code secure
measures
such as people being offered table
service that wasn't being offered
people weren't socially distanced so
again
our team's picking this up um this week
engaging with the event organizer and
also the venue to make sure
that they've got the measures in place
before they undertake another event
another warning is going out and
obviously
the the step will be taken if we have to
to prevent a future event
um if they don't put the measures in
place but obviously we're hoping
um that we don't have to go down that
route
um in terms of businesses we are
unfortunately seeing an increase
in positive cases in businesses so
and the environmental health team
regularly meet with public health
um and we identify businesses that have
got positive
cases and as eleanor said and we're
working with those businesses to try and
stop
um that spread within the business so
we make sure that the the code secure
measures
that are in place at the business are
sufficient
uh to minimize that risk but also that
the business has undertaken its own
contact tracing
because unfortunately some businesses
are waiting to hear from track and trace
rather than taking the proactive step of
identifying the
individuals within their business that
should be self-isolating
so that that's being undertaken and
obviously advice has been given to those
businesses
and hopefully that is keeping cases to a
minimum
we are also going to start encouraging
lateral flow testing within businesses
i think particularly the hospitality
industry have been so heavily impacted
by the pandemic and having to close
there is a reluctance for them to
undertake
lateral flow testing because they
believe that it's going to further
impact
their business and take stuff away and
we're trying to obviously
educate them that actually by taking the
lateral flow test
hopefully it will be an early identifier
of many cases
be they asymptomatic or in the early
stages
to further stop the spread um within the
business
because obviously we've seen
unfortunately in manchester over the
weekend there's been a number of
hospitality businesses
that have had to close because of the
numbers of their staff that have tested
positive or are having to self-isolate
so it's really just trying to get ahead
of the game with them
um we are awaiting further guidance
um as eleanor suggested it's going to be
monday the 14th
of june when the government's obviously
going to announce whether we
will move to the step four step change
on the 21st of june
but we'll keep updated um with the
guidance
and the legislation changes and we'll be
sending out
uh further information to businesses as
and when the guidance comes out
unfortunately we don't get an awful lot
of
time ahead of these step changes to
offer advice but obviously
as soon as we find out we'll send
communications out
and i think that's it for me if anyone's
got any questions
suzanne it's caroline from gmp
hi i just wanted to say a massive thank
you to the environmental health team
and to eleanor actually you've really
helped us to
push issues and deal with them in the
most appropriate way we've got breaches
and we're working on those but without
your help and support
of the environmental health team we
wouldn't have been able to do it so
just wanted to extend my sincere thanks
for that support
oh thank you no problem
thank you caroline thanks susan that was
really that was really informative does
anybody
have any comments or questions for
suzanne
no so thank you very much for that
suzanne if we move on then to
um agenda item 5c which is the mass
vaccination
and who's leading on that
that's me counselors later
hi hi um so i'm stepping in the shoes of
mark jarvis so
my name is manish i'm the deputy medical
director for traffic ccg
um so i'd like to just give some facts
and figures
for our vaccination program i think
we're making really good progress in
traffic
so we're now into cohorts 10 and 12. so
across
all cohorts 1 to 12 we've managed to
vaccinate 70 percent of all eligible
patients
at least once so that's about 130
132 000 patients
um second dose rollouts are continuing
at pace
so we've managed to achieve around 44
of the eligible patients uh who have
already received a second dose
um all cohorts from one to nine
have been offered their vaccination and
about 90 percent
have been vaccinated um we've got good
coverage
for our over 80s and um which
is around 98 now um
care home residents have been vaccinated
to a good standard
again over uh 98
uh this figure does fluctuate with the
patients coming in and out of
nursing homes there is
variation we acknowledge there is
variation in uptake of the vaccinations
across pcns where it's particularly
um challenged in the north but there is
some focused work being done
um in that area to increase the uptake
uh and i think schiller might be uh
describing some of the work that's being
done in that area
um there is we find that there is some
kind of hesitation around the azer
vaccinations
with all the media retentions have had
and we are looking into
possible alternatives to try and address
that issue
so hopefully that's given you a quick
snapshot of uh where we're at and all
the good work that's being done
nicki minaj that was really helpful does
does anybody have any
questions of minis or does anybody have
any comments
looks like no so thank you manish
and if we then move on to um item 5d
which is
community engagement and that
looks like it's jill thank you it is
thank you
thanks counselor slater yeah so i'm
stepping into nigel's
shoes today we're all wearing other
people's shoes aren't we
um i'll give you an update on what the
community engagement team have been
doing over the last
two weeks they've been incredibly busy
and they've been doing some really
effective and important work
um particularly in the north of the
borough but i'll start
just by letting you know that the
community champions
scheme is now fully launched uh
with accompanying press release and
social media and we've got
um people signing up which is really
good to see
um we're keen for as many people as
possible to sign up
as community champions and there's more
details um
including how to sign up on the
council's website
uh we're at the stage now where those
that have signed up will soon be invited
to a q a session with
colleagues in public health and the
community engagement team
and uh they'll be given key messages on
a weekly basis
and as um a community
leaders and trusted people within their
community um
they'll be in a really strong position
to pass those messages on
to engage in dialogue to feed back what
they're hearing
and i think that will help really help
us to uh
connect uh more effectively uh into
communities so that's really exciting
um in terms of the engagement work
that's been undertaken
there's been a community listening
exercise
actually there's been a couple of those
um the biggest of those was
at uh seymour park school
uh in the north of the borough where the
team spoke to over 200 parents and
guardians
in the playground before and after
school um
and just having uh informal
conversations about
how things are going attitudes towards
the pandemic at this particular stage
uh how people feel about um the support
available to self-isolate
um attitudes towards vaccination etc
and we're in the process of analyzing
all of that but i think the headlines
um are worth sharing and that is
it was clear that um family and social
networks
are providing really good support uh to
people in the community people did feel
supported uh only a small minority had
felt the need to kind of reach out to
the community hubs or to the council for
support
also as eleanor mentioned at the
beginning of the meeting
that level of confidence in the vaccine
has clearly increased and the vast
majority
of the parents spoken to said they'd
been vaccinated
and they were mostly kind of awaiting
their second vaccine but there was
very low levels of hesitancy um so that
was really positive to hear and i do
think that's been a change
um in the last few weeks so really good
um and another interesting point they
were asked if they'd had kovid in the
last couple of weeks and um in fact
over 30 said that they had um and i
think that just kind of points to the
fact that you know this was a targeted
piece of work in an area
where we know that there has been
endemic transmission
and where um kopit is still very much um
you know present um within the community
meaning that all of those measures
um that elena talked us through earlier
are still absolutely critical
similar exercise in kings road primary
school the following
week and today and tomorrow
and even bigger exercises underway um
not in schools this time but actually a
door-to-door
knocking exercise um and um we've
identified a target area of around
around six thousand uh residents in the
north of the borough in in the clifford
area and the community engagement team
along with an army of volunteers
are knocking on doors
and again just promoting
that enhanced testing offer a
vaccination
asking people what support they need to
self-isolate
and getting those messages out there
into the community
so really looking forward to being able
to report back to this group
on the outcome of that
we obviously had that enhanced testing
um over the weekend that ben
talked about again the community
engagement team were there to support
that
uh which was um an important element of
that
piece of work and they've also done some
quite targeted work with the homeless
population
in trafford um to understand what the
barriers are to accessing vaccination in
particular
and off the back of that we i think now
have a solution
in place um a mobile vaccination uh
solution um with st john's ambulance
that should be in place very shortly
to make sure that um anyone in that
population
who would like to be vaccinated can be
as easily as possible
so i think that sums up all of the
activity um the only thing
otherwise to mention is that the team
have produced a quarterly report and
that will be circulated to all elected
members
shortly and went to rcg yesterday and so
for
a bit more detail on what they've been
up to in the last three months that that
report is also available
thank absolutely you
the work that you've been doing and i
think that you know i'm really
looking forward to hearing what happens
and from the door knocking sessions that
they're going to be taking place across
and clifford over the next week or so
that's so thank you very much does
anybody haven't yes carl
i think we need to recognize that the
community engagement teams have actually
done an excellent job
where people are being contacted and
coming forward
i think we've now seen a real change in
the attitude of people
on the when we had the hesitancy issue
a couple of weeks ago i think the whole
thing is changing around
now and more and more people are
actually coming for vaccinations
we are seeing that not only in trafford
but across the country as well
in in many areas which is which is the
good news for everyone
thank you khan does anybody else have
any um questions or comments
um from jill's update
looks like no so if we thank you for
that
thanks for the team and everybody that's
been involved if we then can move on to
um
item 5e which is the community
enforcement is that
back to you susan or we already done
that i think we've already done that
helen hasn't given me any further
information about
any kind of community employment
around you know the working together
with yourselves was really helpful as
well so
if we then move on to ice and six which
will be
um engagement for the public sector
a little start again public engagement
board activity so is that over to you
again eleanor
no i think this is mainly for any
um any feedback from any of our
counselors or community groups of work
that they're doing or work that they'd
like to be engaged in
um and any comments that they have on
the work that's been going on already so
i think we've
probably covered quite a bit of it um in
some of the mentioning of some of the
work that's happened but if there are
other
things that people would like to add or
pieces work that they're doing or or
suggestions that they have for work that
we should do
um now's the chance i feel quite
reassured you know with the work that
you're doing around and the north of the
borough because that has been
um quite an issue for us over you know
over this period of time so i feel
really assured with the work that you're
doing and you know obviously i'm looking
forward to seeing some of the results or
hearing some of the results of the work
that and you're going to be undertaking
over the next couple of weeks
and so from my perspective that you know
being a counselor in the north of the
borough that is something that we can
continuously hear is that you know the
uptake isn't as good but
i think that you know we are missing
that actually the uptake
has changed massively you know people
are less
um vaccine hesitant in the north in
certain communities and it's about how
we continue to do the work and support
those other communities that are still a
little hesitant
and what you know and i think that to
hear about that in uh you know in the
next few weeks is going to be really
positive so
i don't know if anybody else has
anything and i can i know that council
knew brushes come on to the call so i
don't know whether or not
you've got anything that you'd like to
say counselor newgross
um it wasn't any uh specific i mean i
a very minor point is that one of my
residents um
has shares the same postcode as lark
hill
and they've had to put up their own
signs to say this is not the vaccination
center
um we've had a lot of success when lark
hill reaches out
and and says we've got vaccine spare can
you
promote it and uh this has you know
we've used social media i've worked
there's many social medias we've used
social media and really driven that
and you know not wasted a drop so that's
been very very useful
um to hear from uh if you do have any
over
let your counselors know ask them to
publicize it
they will and uh yeah we've we've
certainly
um on several occasions been
had that uh success there so no nothing
specific but thank you council slater
very much and that's a really good point
about you know getting that message out
as wide as possible where there is and
some vaccine left over does anybody else
i was just
going out i was i was just going to add
of course that we've talked a lot about
the work in the north but our community
engagement team is split into four parts
one for each neighborhood and they are
working hard in in the other areas as
well some of their work in the north is
perhaps higher profile
but um we have community engagement
people working in each
each of the areas um some more intensive
work going on in partington but also
with different communities in
in south and central um trafford as well
so it's
um it's important we don't forget that
we're making sure that
everybody is covered
does anybody else want to come in with
any comments or questions at this point
or tell us about any good work that
they've been made aware of that we could
piggyback on and use in traffic
i think i want to make a general comment
that
a lot of work is being done by many
people and
i think that is actually as i said
earlier on is bearing fruit
um we are beginning to see a big change
um and now i think what we are and also
uh it was said earlier on that the
teenagers are doing a good job
in the communications field
which i think is very good also
from the voluntary sector i think we are
we are continuing to engage with people
we are continuing to tell people to go
and get the vaccination wherever it is
possible
because some can go you know wherever
they want to go
um so really it is a good story
in the sense that we are actually coming
we are coming on top of everything else
and i think that's something which is
very positive for everyone
you can't i agree dorothy did you want
to
comment i can see you've taken your
microphone off
i can't hear you i know that you've all
muted
wanna try again
can you hear me now okay
um i just wanted to talk about the work
that we've been doing along with
the caribbean and african health network
we've been having
um several sessions particularly around
vaccine hesitancy um for our
community and that takes place in the
form of a health hour
in form of um leaflets and publications
and actually going out and talking to
people
um now that we as an organization are
opening up and having people back we're
able to have more regular face-to-face
conversations with individuals
away from their families just to have
that direct conversation to have an
understanding of
why people may be hesitant and what
we're actually finding is that people
are
if they were hesitant they're now
um quite willing to take up the vaccine
but there has been
some issues around as you say um
transport
and getting to vaccination centers so
where we can
we have been uh trying to support with
that and particularly making people
aware that
there is the option of contacting the gp
and the gps will arrange transport so i
think in relation to the transport issue
where there is a problem we should be
raising the fact that people should be
highlighting any barriers that they may
be facing particularly in relation to
transport
with the gp so that can be resolved
thank you doctor that's really helpful
and you know i think
it's quite clear we can be quite mobile
with some of the
vaccination and clinics and stuff that
we're going to be able to do so i think
that if people do speak
up and you know let public health and
others know
you know gp or whatever know that you
know that there's a certain area
struggling we can have a look at
what support we can provide to that area
so that we can get as many people
vaccinated as possible so
that's really helpful thank you um is
there anybody else
no it looks like no so if we move on to
has anybody got any other business
and that looks like i know so thank you
everybody we've been able to do this in
an hour so i've been able to share it
for the hour so
thanks everybody and you know and i look
forward to seeing
uh the results of everything that you
you know you're all working on so thank
you everybody and have a good day
thank you very much bye